nos dicen el maíz se usa como alimento y
como insumo en la producción de etanol
un combustible alternativo supón que el
maíz se produce en un mercado de
competencia perfecta dibuja dos gráficas
lado a lado etiquetadas correctamente
del mercado de maíz y de un granjero
representativo en las gráficas muestra
lo siguiente el precio y la cantidad de
equilibrio en el mercado de maíz
etiquetados peso m y q sub m
respectivamente la cantidad que maximiza
la ganancia del granjero donde obtiene
una ganancia económica 0 etiquetada q
sub
efe como siempre pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo por su cuenta antes
de que lo resolvamos juntos muy bien
vamos a resolverlos juntos lo primero
que haremos es dibujar graficas lado a
lado etiquetadas correctamente este es
el eje horizontal para el mercado y este
es el eje horizontal para el granjero
esta es la cantidad en el mercado y esta
será la cantidad para el granjero este
será el precio para el mercado y
cualquiera que sea el precio en el
mercado también será el precio que el
granjero tiene que aceptar ya que aquí
dice que es un
de competencia perfecta por lo que el
granjero será precio aceptante este es
el precio del mercado y este es el
precio del granjero
esta es la gráfica para el mercado de
maíz ya hemos hecho esto varias veces la
curva de demanda se ve más o menos así
porque cuando el precio es alto hay poca
cantidad demandada y cuando el precio es
bajo aumenta la cantidad demandada y la
curva de la oferta es lo contrario luce
más o menos así este punto nos ayuda a
ubicar el precio de equilibrio en el
mercado que es peso m y esta será la
cantidad de equilibrio curso m ahora
esta gráfica es para el granjero el
granjero es precio aceptante por lo que
va a tener que aceptar cualquiera que
sea el precio en el mercado el precio
del mercado es el ingreso marginal del
granjero ahora nos dicen la cantidad que
maximiza la ganancia del granjero donde
obtiene una ganancia económica cero
etiquetada q sub f por lo que vamos a
tener la cantidad que maximiza la
ganancia pero también tenemos una
ganancia económica cero y la ganancia
económica cero nos dice que el precio
debe ser igual
total promedio en esa cantidad dibujo
una curva de costo total promedio que se
ve así y voy a hacer que el punto mínimo
interese que al precio del mercado
porque hemos visto en vídeos anteriores
que la cantidad que maximiza la ganancia
ocurre donde el costo marginal intersec
al ingreso marginal que en este caso es
el precio que el granjero tiene que
aceptar del mercado y sabemos que la
curva del costo marginal intersec aa la
curva de costo total promedio en este
punto mínimo así que dibujo la curva de
costo marginal más o menos así y noten
que el costo marginal intersec a al
costo total promedio en este punto
mínimo lo que ya hemos explicado en
varios vídeos y en un vídeo anterior
explicamos que la cantidad que maximiza
la ganancia es la cantidad donde se
encuentra el costo marginal y el ingreso
marginal aquí el precio es el ingreso
marginal más allá de ese punto cada
unidad adicional será una pérdida para
el granjero ya que tendrá que usar más
recursos para producir esa unidad de lo
que podrá obtener por ella en el mercado
y también se menciona que esta es una
situación de ganancia
pero porque el costo total promedio
tiene que estar en ese precio tiene que
estar donde está el ingreso marginal por
lo que esta será la cantidad que
maximiza la ganancia q sub efe y
terminamos